MASSIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR US HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES AND SOON.
LIVE UPDATES FOR THAT ON YOU IN
JUST A MOMENT.
THE FIRST, A POLITICAL TRAGEDY
NOW UNFOLDING HERE IN AMERICA.
THE SELF IMMOLATION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS HAPPENING,
IT BEGINS TOMORROW IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
LIKE ALL POLITICAL LEADERS, WAY
BACK IN THE THE YEAR, IT WOULD
AMOUNT TO AN OBAMA RESTORATION
BY BEATING THE DRUM WE CAN ALL
RETURN TO THE WORLD BEFORE
TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN WAS A DESIGNATED
LEADER OF THIS COUNTERREVOLUTION
AND IT’S ALL A LITTLE HARD TO
BELIEVE NOW THAT BIDEN IS IN
DANGER OF FINISHING FIFTH
TOMORROW I NEW HAMPSHIRE BUT
THAT’S WHAT THEY REALLY THOUGHT.
THEY SAID SO RIGHT ON TV.
>> HE JUST DECIDED TO BYPASS THE
PRIMARIES AND GO RIGHT TO THE
MAIN EVENT AND CAN SIGN
EVERYBODY ELSE TO THE KIDDIE
TABLE.
>> THAT IS JOE BIDEN AT HIS
BEST, THAT IS SOMEONE WHO IS
AUTHENTIC, IT IS THE REASON HE
CONNECTS WITH PEOPLE.
>> TODAY, THE MAN WHO HAS BEEN A
SENATOR, A VICE PRESIDENT AND A
BIG FAN OF AVIATORS IS JOINING
THE RACE.
>> THE AVIATORS ARE BACK, THEY
ARE THE AVIATORS AND HE LOVES
THIS, HE IS HAVING FUN.
THIS IS NOT HEAVY LIFTING FOR
JOE BIDEN.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
THRILLING TO MAKE HIM A VERY
AMERICAN, I THOUGHT IT WAS
GREAT.
>> Tucker: I’M GLAD WE SAVE
THE TAPE, I WISH WE HADN’T.
HE’S GOT SOME COOL SUNGLASSES,
HE IS ON THE FIRE, EVERYONE ELSE
IS AT THE KIDDIE TABLE, HE IS
GOT THIS IN THE BAG.
THAT WAS THEIR VIEW.
AND THEN HE STARTED RUNNING
WHICH MEANT TALKING.
NOT THE USUAL PAID SPEECHES TO
INVESTOR CONFERENCES BUT ACTUAL
IN PERSON CAMPAIGN EVENTS WHERE
THERE IS NO TELEPROMPTER AND
PEOPLE CAN ASK YOU WHATEVER THEY
WANT.
THINGS QUICKLY COLLAPSED.
>> NO MAN HAS A RIGHT TO RAISE A
HAND TO A WOMAN IN ANGER OTHER
THAN IN SELF DEFENSE FUND THAT
IS RARELY EVER OCCURRING, SO WE
HAVE TO JUST CHANGE THE CULTURE
AND KEEP PUNCHING AT IT AND
PUNCHING AT IT AND PUNCHING AT
IT.
I LOVE THIS PLACE.
WHAT’S NOT TO LIKE ABOUT VERMONT
IN TERMS OF THE BEAUTY OF IT AND
WHAT A NEAT TOWN?
>> MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD
PLAYER ON AT NIGHT.
THEY ARE JUST AS GREAT AND JUST
AS TALENTED AS WHITE KIDS.
>> WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS.
>> Tucker: SEE?
THE ANSWER TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS MORE PUNCHING AND IF YOU
DON’T BELIEVE IT, TURN ON THE
RECORD PLAYER.
EVERY DAY, A NEW DISASTER ALL
CHRONICLED ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
STILL THE PROGNOSTICATORS
ASSURED US THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
THE INEVITABLE WINNER, HE HAD TO
BE.
THE SOUTH CAROLINA PRIMARY IS
COMING UP, HAS A LOCK ON
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, BLACK PEOPLE
LOVE HIM.
WHATEVER YOU SAY, CABLE NEWS
GENIUSES.
WE JUST GOT THE NEW QUINNIPIAC
BOWL THAT SHOWS BIDEN DROPPING
22 POINTS AMONG BLACK VOTERS IN
JUST TWO WEEKS.
HE IS AT 15 POINTS AMONG THOSE
SAME VOTERS, IT PROVES THAT IN
POLITICS AS IN LIFE, YOU NEVER
REALLY KNOW.
WHO BETTER TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THAT.
KEEP IN MIND, THESE PEOPLE COME
ON THE JUST SAW GET HUGE
SALARIES TO PREDICT THE FUTURE
YET THEY ARE VIRTUALLY ALWAYS
WRONG.
A FRUSTRATING?
IT IS FRUSTRATING.
WE STILL REMEMBER WHEN THEY WERE
TELLING US TO BUY CONDOS IN
VEGAS BEFORE THE 2008
REAL ESTATE COLLAPSE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THEY
CONSISTENT IDIOCY DOES A
LUCRATIVE INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITY.
EVERY TIME SOMEONE ON THESE
PANELS, "WASHINGTON POST" NEXT
TO THE RETIRED ANALYST ACROSS
FROM THE FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR AND THE FAKE
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST WHO IS
NEVER WON A CAMPAIGN, EVERY TIME
THEY AGREE SOMETHING MOMENTOUS
IS JUST ABOUT TO HAPPEN, BET
AGAINST IT AND GO ALL IN WHEN
YOU DO, TAKE A MORTGAGE OUT ON
THE HOUSE AGAIN, GET A LOAN FROM
YOUR BROTHER-IN-LAW, COLLECT THE
DIMES FROM UNDER YOUR COUCH AND
SEND IT ALL TO YOUR BROKER.
GO LONG AGAINST THE CONSENSUS ON
CABLE NEWS AND YOU WILL GET
RICH.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS BUT WE CAN BE CERTAIN OF
AT LEAST ONE THING IN THE WORLD,
WHEN EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON SAYS
IT’S TRUE, IT IS NOT TRUE.
THE OPPOSITE USUALLY IS TRUE.
APPARENTLY JOE BIDEN HASN’T
QUITE FIGURED THIS OUT YET WHICH
IS WHY HE STILL RUNNING.
STILL MAKING CANDIDATE LIKE
NOISES OUT THERE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL BY TURNING THE BAFFLING
NUMBER OF VOTERS WHO COME OUT TO
SEE HIM, HERE IS HIS LATEST
EXCHANGE.
>> IT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
NUMBER ONE, I WAS A DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS, EVER BEEN TO A CAUCUS?
NO, YOU HAVEN’T.
YOU ARE A LYING DOG FACED PONY
SOLDIER.
NOW YOU’VE GOT TO BE HONEST.
I’M GOING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: TAKE THAT, HE WAS
LYING DOG FACE PONY SOLDIER!
IT’S GOING TO BE HARD NOT TO
MISS JOE BIDEN WHEN HE DROPS
OUT.
IN THE MEANTIME, HERE’S A LINE
HE CAN USE THE NEXT TIME SEVEN
VOTER DARES TO ASK HIM WHY HE’S
LOSING.
>> USED LIVE MEETING DOG, YOU
SCUM SUCKING PIG, SON OF A
MOTHER THIS CODE.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN JUST HEAR
BIDEN SAYING THAT.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL GET TO THAT IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, LET’S HOPE IN
THE END IT’S NOT REALLY FAIR TO
BLAME HIM FOR THIS MESS.
SHALLOW PEOPLE WITH A RAPIDLY
DECLINING FACULTY SHOULDN’T BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SOON, PROBABLY VERY SOON HE WILL
BE SAFELY IN FLORIDA WEARING
WHITE KNEE SOCKS AND ENJOYING A
PRIME RIB SPECIAL.
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ENCOURAGED
HIM TO RUN DESPITE THE EVIDENCE
AND PREDICTED HIS VICTORY, WE
SHOULD REMEMBER THEIR NAMES.
THEY ARE NOT SENILE, JUST
STUPID.
TO BE FAIR, THERE ARE STILL SOME
VOTERS OUT THERE WHO SINCERELY
BELIEVE JOE BIDEN CAN WIN IT
ALL.
AND SOMEHOW, THEIR ENTHUSIASM
SEEMS EVEN MORE HURTFUL THAN THE
ATTACKS ON HIS ENEMIES.
HERE’S THE LATEST SPASM OF BIDEN
SUPPORT FROM NEW HAMPSHIRE.
>> [SINGING]
>> Tucker: BIDEN’S BACK,
ALL RIGHT.
EVER SEE ANYTHING SADDER THAN
THAT?
NOT SINCE THE LAST REUNION TO
REPLAY THE WICHITA COUNTY FAIR.
TIME IS THE COOLEST CRITIC OF
ALL.
BIDEN HIMSELF SEEMED UNCERTAIN
OF WHAT TO MAKE OF ALL THE
PRAISE, HE HAD THAT VACANT
SLIGHTLY CONFUSED LOOK LIKE HE
JUST BEEN TOLD A BLOW OUT THE
CANDLES ON HIS 90TH BIRTHDAY
CAKE.
NONE OF THIS AMUSES DEMOCRATIC
OFFICIALS IN WASHINGTON.
THEY KNOW THEIR PARTIES IN
DANGER OF NOT HAVING A NOMINEE
AT ALL BY THE TIME THE
CONVENTION ARRIVES.
HERE’S A DIFFERENCE, MOST AWARD
DELEGATES TO THE WINNER OF THE
STATES BUT NOT SO IN THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
THANKS TO CHANGES THAT
BERNIE SANDERS DEMANDED AFTER
THE LAST ELECTION, MANY THINK
ANDDELEGATES ARE ON A PROPORTION
SIDE OF WHICH MEANS IF THEY ARE
IN THE RACE AFTER SUPER TUESDAY,
THEY WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY BE A
BROKERED CONVENTION AND A BETTER
ONE.
IS VERY BAD NEWS FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT THEY RAN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE
STARTING TO FIGURE THAT OUT AND
THEY ARE UPSET.
>> IT IS A CERTAIN PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT WANTS US
TO BE A COLD.
I AM NOT INTERESTED IN BEING IN
A COLD.
SOME PEOPLE WANT A REVOLUTION, I
DON’T KNOW, THEY SCREAM AT
PEOPLE, THEY GO AND BULLY PEOPLE
AND I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU’RE
STANDING UP AND SCREAMING AND A
MICROPHONE ABOUT THE REVOLUTION
BUT YOU HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE AN
ALTERNATIVE.
>> Tucker: AT THE END, YOU
HEARD WHAT IT’S REALLY ABOUT.
THEIR MAIN FEAR IS
BERNIE SANDERS.
WILL PUT UP WITH ALMOST ANY
AMOUNT OF SOCIAL ENGINEERING,
NONBINARY BATHROOMS, CHECK BUT
THEY TEND TO BE COMPLETELY
HUMORLESS ON THE SUBJECT OF
MONEY WHEN IT COMES TO HANDLING
THEIR MONEY TO THE PEOPLE BELOW
THEM.
THEY GET HYSTERICAL AND START
RANTING ABOUT PUBLIC EXECUTIONS.
>> I WILL BE GLAD TO SHARE THEM
WITH YOU IN PRIVATE AND IT GOES
BACK TO THE EARLY 1950s.
I REMEMBER, I HAVE AN ATTITUDE
TOWARDS CASTRO, I BELIEVE IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN EXECUTIONS IN
CENTRAL PARK AND I MIGHT’VE BEEN
ONE OF THE ONES GETTING EXECUTED
AND CERTAIN OTHER PEOPLE WOULD
BE THERE CHEERING SO I HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH PEOPLE ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT HE MEANS,
THAT’S HARMLESS, A LOT OF GOOD
SOCIAL WELFARE PROGRAMS, IT’S
HARMLESS.
>> PRETTY CLEARLY ON THE DENMARK
CATEGORY.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW, DID HE TELL
YOU THAT?
>> Tucker: STOP BURNING, THAT
IS THE FOCUS RIGHT NOW
DEMOCRATIC CIRCLES IN WASHINGTON
THAT IS ALL THEY ARE THINKING
ABOUT.
THEY FEAR BERNIE MORE THAN
TRUMP, THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
THEY STOP HIM?
PROBABLY NOT WITH AMY KLOBUCHAR
SO THAT LEAVES TWO FORMER MAYORS
TO GET THE JOB DONE.
NOW, A LOT OF DONORS IN NEW YORK
AND LOS ANGELES WOULD RATHER GO
WITH THE FORMER, PETE BUTTIGIEG
OF SOUTH BEND WITH ONE THING HE
WAS NEVER A REPUBLICAN LIKE MIKE
BLOOMBERG BUT THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM, AND THE
MAIN ONE IS NOT CAN HE BECOME
PRESIDENT, THE MAIN ONE IS IS HE
ACTUALLY HUMAN?
DOES HE LEAVE FOOTPRINTS, HAS HE
EVER CAST A SHADOW OR IS HE
EXACTLY WHAT HE APPEARS TO BE?
A CORPORATE HOLOGRAM DESIGNED BY
THE HR DEPARTMENT FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES?
WHO KNOWS, BUT IT IS POSSIBLE AI
IS NOW SO SOPHISTICATED WE ARE
LOOKING AT OUR FIRST ROBOTIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
YOU WILL NOTICE EVERY WORD HE
UTTERS HIS PERFECTLY
SYNCHRONIZED WITH THE OFFICIAL
VIEW FROM SILICON VALLEY AND THE
FINANCE WORLD.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES OF THAT
OCCURRING IN NATURE?
THIS MAY BE THE NEW FRONTIER IN
AUTOMATION, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
FOR THE OTHER CANDIDATES CLEARLY
DON’T KNOW WHAT TO MAKE OF THE
WHOLE THING.
BIDEN TOOK THE FIRST SWING IN A
NASTY NEW TELEVISION AD WHEN
JOE BIDEN CALLS YOU ON
ACCOMPLISHED, IT STINGS.
>> WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA CALLED
ON HIM, JOE BIDEN HELPED LEAD
THE PASSAGE OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT WHICH GAVE HEALTH CARE
TO 20 MILLION PEOPLE.
AND WHEN PART GOERS -- GIVING
CITIZENS OF SOUTH BEND
COLORFULLY ILLUMINATED RIVERS.
UNDER THREAT OF A NUCLEAR IRAN,
JOE BIDEN HELPED NEGOTIATE THE
IRAN DEAL AND UNDER THREAT OF
DISAPPEARING PETS,
PETE BUTTIGIEG NEGOTIATED
LIGHTER LICENSING REGULATIONS ON
SCANNERS.
>> Tucker: OKAY, BUT CAN WE BE
HONEST FOR ONE MOMENT?
WHICH WOULD YOU ACTUALLY RATHER
HAVE?
A CHIP SCANNER THAT HELPED FIND
HER LOST DOG?
IT’S AN INTERESTING QUESTION
ANYWAY, BIDEN LEFT UNANSWERED.
NEVERTHELESS, THE OTHER
CANDIDATES FOLLOWED HIS LEAD AND
PUSHED A SIMILAR THEME, WATCH.
>> WE HAVE A NEWCOMER AND THE
WHITE HOUSE AND LOOK WHERE IT
GOT US.
I THINK HAVING SOME EXPERIENCE
IS A GOOD THING.
>> THAT’S WHY I’M WORRIED ABOUT
MAYOR PETE.
HE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
TOE-TO-TOE WITH THIS GUY AND
TAKE HIM DOWN ON THE DEBATE
STAGE OR WE ARE GOING TO LOSE.
>> UNLIKE SOME OF THE FOLKS UP
HERE, I DON’T HAVE 40
BILLIONAIRES CONTRIBUTE INTO MY
CAMPAIGN.
COMING FROM THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY, COMING FROM
WALL STREET.
>> I DON’T THINK ANY BILLIONAIRE
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO DO IT AND I
DON’T THINK PEOPLE WHO SUCK UP
TO BILLIONAIRES IN ORDER TO FUND
THEIR CAMPAIGN OUGHT TO DO IT.
>> Tucker: SAYS THE LADY WHO
JUST GOT OFF A PRIVATE PLANE AND
THE OTHER DAY.
ALL SEEMS UNFAIR IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
THERE WAS TOM STEYER WHO IS
CURRENTLY SUFFERING WITHIN ONE
OF THE WORST MIDLIFE CRISES AND
REPORTED HISTORY, NEVER BEEN
ELECTED TO ANYTHING AND NEVER
WILL BE ATTACKING PETE BUTTIGIEG
FOR NOT BEING ACCOMPLISHED
ENOUGH.
IRONY IS DEFINITELY DEAD.
ON THE OTHER HAND, SO IS
PETE BUTTIGIEG’S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN NO MATTER WHAT THEY ARE
CLAIMING ON TELEVISION.
HE IS TOO FAKE, TOO UNNERVINGLY
PROGRAMMED, HE IS NOT GOING TO
WIN.
WE’VE ALREADY GOT ONE FOR YOU
WHO HAS TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO SPEND ON THE RACE,
LET’S BE HONEST, THE DEMOCRATIC
CONTEST AS OF TONIGHT IS NOW
BETWEEN MIKE BLOOMBERG AND
BERNIE SANDERS.
THAT’S A DISASTER FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE PARTY CAN EITHER NOMINATE
BERNIE AND GO FULL SOCIALIST OR
STEAL THE NOMINATION FROM BERNIE
AND FACE SOME SORT OF REAL
CATACLYSM AT THE CONVENTION AND
BEYOND MILWAUKEE.
THOSE ARE THE OPTIONS.
EITHER WAY, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME AFTER